as you stand at your window looking out
at a sky filled with dark clouds that
are pouring down sheets of rain and hail
suddenly it happens a twisting column of
gray descends from the clouds at first
it's just hanging there suspended above
the land but it soon reaches down and
makes contact with the ground at the
same time it turns even darker as it
picks up dirt and debris if you're lucky
you make it to a shelter before you can
witness the immense swirling winds
pulling up animals cars and buildings in
its wake this harsh reality can occur
anywhere in the world however by a wide
margin most tornadoes happen in the
United States more than if you combined
the yearly average number of tornadoes
in every country in the rest of the
world the US is also the only country to
regularly experience tornadoes that
reach the highest classification of
violent which caused the highest
percentage of deaths each year in the
United States there are over a a
thousand reported tornadoes and on
average these result in around 80
casualties but some years it's much
worse like in 2011 the 2011 Super
outbreak was the largest costliest and
one of the deadliest tornado outbreaks
ever recorded taking place in the
southern Midwestern and Northeastern
United States from April 25th to 28th it
resulted in roughly 12 billion dollars
in Damages and left an estimated 321
people dead tornado deaths are caused
when an individual is picked up by the
strong winds or when they're struck by a
large chunk of flying debris while the
death rate is significantly lower than
it was in the early 1900s the seemingly
random and spontaneous nature of
tornadoes makes them one of the most
difficult to predict weather phenomena
current forecasts of incoming tornadoes
only provide an average of an 8.4 minute
lead time and in a scenario where not
only your possession are at stake but
the lives of you and your family every
second counts how and why do some
tornadoes become so destructive and just
how big can they get and how might we
one day be able to predict them better
foreign
for such a well-known phenomenon we know
surprisingly little about how tornadoes
actually form and understanding how they
form is crucial for developing better
tornado prediction models some
scientists risk their own lives by
getting up close and personal with these
violent storms all in an effort to
determine exactly what's happening in
and around the tornado most tornadoes
begin with a supercell a storm with a
persistent rotating updraft at its core
supercells form due to a particular
combination of winds when wind speed and
direction are different at different
altitudes this is called wind shear when
wind at ground level is blowing One
Direction and wind higher in the
atmosphere is blowing another Direction
it can cause a horizontal tube of air to
form then as warm humid air rises and
cool air Falls the horizontal tube of
rotating air can be pushed to become a
vertical one called a Vortex or a
mesocyclone which can have a diameter of
5 to 20 kilometers at this point the
whole storm starts rotating and the
supercell is born this type of storm is
the parent of most tornadoes near the
ground the mesocyclone can be narrowed
by the strong updraft this process
called Vortex stretching speeds up the
circulation this creates a funnel cloud
then the downdraft brings the rotation
down to the ground and a tornado is born
low pressure systems in the U.S pull
warm moist air from the Gulf of Mexico
and cool dry air Aloft from the Rocky
Mountains or the high desert in the
southwest creating consistent wind shear
the states that fall between these
regions end up being in the ideal
location for severe tornadoes to form
but this is all a bit of an
approximation exactly what the right
conditions are for tornadoes to form is
still a bit of a mystery in an effort to
answer the many questions remaining
about tornado formation the NOAA
National of your Storm's lab launched a
research project in 1995 called the
verification of the origins of rotation
in tornado's experiment or more simply
Vortex there were several iterations the
largest of which Vortex 2 took place in
2009 it included over a hundred
scientists who used Cutting Edge
Equipment to analyze weather
measurements taken around supercell
thunderstorms across 10 000 miles of the
Southern and Central U.S an area dubbed
Tornado Alley over the span of one month
they collected data from 11 supercell
storms including one supercell tornado
the results from this project indicated
that tornado formation is related to the
temperature differences at the edges of
the spinning air but that might not
always be the case mathematical models
and real-life observations have
demonstrated that tornadoes can arise
with very little temperature difference
clearly there's a lot more to uncover on
exactly what makes a tornado form how
they dissipate is not much clearer
scientists are still debating the
details but generally a tornado stops
when it loses its source of instability
like heat or moisture or its vorticity
one way this could happen is by
encountering a cold flow of wind from a
rainstorm called an outflow but of
course it's what happens between its
formation and dissipation that's really
important how much damage did it cause
how many lives did it take just how
destructive was it this is what a
tornado's rating is based on after a
tornado has ended experts examine and
tally up the damage they look at what
type of buildings were affected and how
badly they suffered they then used the
enhanced Fujita Scale to assign a rating
from zero to five this assessment is
also used to estimate wind speeds
varying from 100 to over 320 kilometers
per hour and assessing the damage is
often the only way scientists can
estimate how strong a tornado was since
it's rare that they're able to take a
direct wind speed measurement and
sometimes the damage is absolutely
catastrophic out of those that have had
their wind speed directly measured the
tornado with the highest wind speed
began in Bridge Creek Oklahoma on May
3rd 1999 during a massive tornado
outbreak involving over 70 tornadoes
this particular ef-4 EF5 tornado
traveled across heavily populated areas
in Oklahoma and with wind speeds topping
512 kilometers per hour it completely
obliterated over 200 homes over the
course of one and a half hours killing
36 people it was classified as an EF5
because the EF5 category has no upper
limit but its wind speeds were so fast
some scientists think it should have
fallen into its own new category an ef-6
the problem with creating an ef6
category is that the vast majority of
struck structures are simply gone at the
EF5 rating and besides the rare tornado
like the Bridge Creek Moor tornado that
has its wind speed directly measured the
rating comes from the destruction it
leaves behind and complete and total
obliteration looks the same if the wind
was 350 kilometers per hour or 550
kilometers per hour scientists believe
that theoretically the fastest tornado
possible on Earth would be 611
kilometers per hour The Bridge Creek
Moore tornado was not far off but while
the Bridge Creek more tornado certainly
was devastating it was not even close to
the deadliest on April 26 1989 a single
tornado in Bangladesh took at least 1300
lives and left 80 000 homeless it was
estimated to be an ef-4 tornado with
wind speeds of 338 to 418 kilometers per
hour the devastation was so complete
that except for some skeletons of trees
there were no signs that there had ever
been any standing structures and the
deadliest tornado in U.S history was the
Tri-State Tornado on March 18 1925 which
resulted in a death toll of a whopping
695 people one tornado killing almost
twice as many as the super outbreak in
2011 which was made up of 300 separate
tornadoes the Tri-State tornado's name
comes from its Journey from Southern
Missouri to Illinois to Indiana totaling
350 kilometers this also made it the
tornado with the longest path which took
about three and a half hours during this
time it destroyed 15
000 homes earning it a ranking of an
ef-5 but with a maximum width of about
1.5 to 2.5 kilometers neither the
Tri-State nor the bridge Creek tornadoes
were the biggest tornadoes in history
the widest ever recorded reached an
absolutely massive width of 4.2
kilometers this occurred around El Reno
Oklahoma on May 31st 2013 and lasted
about 40 minutes luckily it remained
mainly in rural areas and was raided in
ef-3 so while winds reached 484
kilometers per hour its damage was
limited wide tornadoes aren't usually
the deadliest however this one did
result in the deaths of eight
individuals three of which were the
first Storm Chasers ever to be killed in
a tornado these deadly events are a
bone-chilling reminder of just how
ruthless nature can be for anyone who
lives were tornadoes frequent all they
can hope for is a fair warning to get
themselves somewhere safe
currently meteorologists can identify
weather conditions that could result in
a severe storm days in advance but
determining exactly when or where a
tornado will form is much more difficult
a lot of that difficulty is due to the
relatively small scale of a tornado
while storms can cover large areas even
multiple States tornadoes are usually
less than a kilometer wide once a storm
forms predicting a tornado becomes a lot
easier using Doppler radar systems
meteorologists can watch a storm and
provide a risk assessment for a certain
area something like there's a 20 chance
of a tornado over these 40 kilometers
most often tornado warnings made by the
National Weather Service turn out to be
false alarms this happens up to 80
percent of the time of course it's
always better to be safe than sorry
especially when you only have a few
minutes to prepare when a tornado does
end up forming but can we do better
while most people would run from a
tornado it's a storm chaser's job to get
in front of it they set up scientific
equipment along what they hope will be
its path that will take important
measurements as the tornado travels over
it as we've already discussed there are
still a lot of unknowns about how and
why tornadoes form but we know a lot
more than we used to and that's thanks
to these incredibly Brave individuals
most of whom are meteorologists
including one of the Storm Chasers who
lost his life in the El Reno tornado his
name was Tim Samaras and he was
extremely passionate about his work he
once said that a ground-based
measurement taken from within a tornado
is especially crucial because it
provides data about the lowest 10 meters
of a tornado where houses vehicles and
people are other scientists have agreed
that the rapidly changing conditions low
to the ground may be what's controlling
a tornado's formation this data could
not only help scientists to better
understand tornadoes but would improve
their forecasts and help design
structures that are able to withstand
intense winds but of course making a
technical instrument that can withstand
these winds itself is no easy task and
scientists had once given up on it that
was until May 7 2002 when Tim Samaras
deployed a probe of his own design that
survived a direct hit from an ef-3
tornado while recording changes in
pressure wind speed and direction and
air temperature and relative humidity
with this device he and his team went on
to collect video and data from inside
several tornadoes providing the
scientific Community with invaluable
information but collecting this data is
just one piece of the puzzle and
scientists are still developing better
detection methods and Warning Systems
these include new types of radar
technology such as phased array radar
which can scan the entire sky in less
than one minute five times faster than
current radar systems scientists are
also building better forecasts and
prediction models these use current
weather and radar data to simulate what
the atmosphere will look like in the
future to make them more accurate
scientists are trying to to increase
their resolution because not only are
tornadoes small compared to
thunderstorms but what's happening
inside a tornado changes in temperature
pressure humidity and wind is occurring
on the molecular level and while a model
of every molecule involved in a storm
may not be possible right now we may one
day have the Computing capacity to do so
but even if we are never able to predict
a tornado days ahead of time gaining
just an hour's notice could save
countless lives
to get up-to-date information on big
storm events almost everyone relies on
the news we've all anxiously tracked
thunderstorms coming in to ruin our
plans or checked reports of how much
damage a recent storm caused and what
the government's plans are for Aid and
reconstruction we've also all felt sorry
for storm reporters getting blasted in
the face by snow or clinging on for dear
life as hurricane force wind pushes them
around when it comes to storm
information we all kind of assume the
news will give it to us straight but
these days in the world of
sensationalism and competition for
clicks it's hard to know what's being
overblown and what are the simple facts
with hundreds of news sources out there
it's downright annoying trying to sift
through all the nonsense this is why a
good news aggregator app like ground
news is so helpful it's an app I use
every morning to understand the news in
a quick simple unbiased way
ground news is a website and app
developed by a former NASA engineer on a
mission to give readers an easy
data-driven objective way to read the
news
every story comes with a quick visual
breakdown of the political bias
factuality and ownership of the sources
reporting all backed by ratings from
three Independent News monitoring
organizations
you can quickly swipe through the
different headlines that different news
outlets are giving to the same story
sometimes the differences are subtle
other times not at all you can also see
which news outlets are choosing to
ignore or under report stories that are
being widely reported Elsewhere for
example if you look up topics like
tornadoes or climate change on ground
news you can see that most stories
receive far more left-leaning coverage I
sort of expected the climate change bias
but tornado coverage bias why it gets
even more biased when you click into
stories like this one about how the
Democratic governor of Kentucky's
efforts to help storm-torn areas might
hurt the GOP advantage in rural areas
this story was reported on by 18
different outlets and has a 44 left lean
in coverage and a zero percent
right-leaning coverage I know I'm going
to get a thousand salty comments about
my left-leaning bias even talking about
this but the true truth is readers from
any political leaning can identify media
bias and check Source credibility with
ground news there's even a web browser
extension that can show you the
breakdown of how news outlets from
across the political Spectrum are
reporting on the same story this helps
you immediately notice certain bias
Trends which is helpful but also
fascinating seeing the different choice
of words and headlines from different
organizations while also seeing their
bias flagged is a super effective way to
see exactly how prominent and widespread
news bias really is it adds another
layer of interest to reading The Daily
News so if you're looking for a better
way to stay informed about current
events around the world check out ground
news by visiting ground.news real
science the link is in the description
you can try it free or subscribe to get
access to all the features you see here
and support transparent Independent News
but ground news is also offering all
real science viewers a special 30
discount on their Vantage subscription
the top level subscription option this
includes access to a feature called my
news bias which is basically a dashboard
for your news diet sign up to see how
your reading habits change over the next
week what are your top sources are you
engaging with diverse perspectives what
about your favorite topics this offer is
only available at ground.news real
science or by clicking the link in the
video description